So your question is how widespread is it
with a NASA that scientists are
convinced that human activity is
responsible for climate change and this
is something that's important to say
very,
very clearly.
I have known and worked with hundreds of
earth scientists at many different
locations in NASA.
All of them,
all of them believe that human activity
is responsible for the current climate
change that we see going so fast.
It's almost unprecedented.
I want you to think about that.
One thing that I take really seriously
and I'm very proud of is that NASA is
not a political organization.
We are scientists that work for the
American people were funded by taxpayer
money,
and what we do is we make measurements.
We have many,
many different satellites that are
orbiting the earth right now.
They're looking at things like ice on
the oceans at the polls.
They're looking for things like
vegetation growth and the change of that
ocean level is the ocean level rising.
Yeah.
Turns out that it is.
So we have many scientists all over the
planet studying all of the different
ramifications of climate change.
We understand the causes.
There actually is no scientific
controversy about that.
Humans are releasing greenhouse gases
into the atmosphere and this is warming
our planet.
Now,
what scientists are researching
currently and they don't all agree about
is what are the most important
components of driving climate change?
Is it carbon dioxide?
It could it be something else like
methane and methane gets released.
That's an even more powerful greenhouse
gas.
We don't agree on how quickly things
like the ocean level will rise.
People have different estimates for how
quickly that will happen,
so there still is scientific controversy
about what the most important aspects of
climate change are and how quickly it
will go in the future,
but there is no scientific disagreement
with a NASA that humans are causing
climate change.
Now,
I started this off by saying that one of
the things I'm very proud of is that
NASA is not political and what that
means for me is that I cannot advocate
for any specific solution to climate
change.
That's not my job.
That's up to policymakers.
The people might suggest things like
having more solar energy or cutting
carbon emissions or things like that,
but at Nasa we really understand that's
not us.
That's up to the American people are
leaders and leaders around the world.
What we do is provide the facts to
everybody on the planet.
All of our data is actually free to any
government,
any person,
any scientists all over the world that
wants to use it,
so we all know what's causing climate
change.
We can't tell you what to do about it,
but we can say it's time to do something
about it.